This video is made possible by brilliance.
You're going to learn more about
brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to get started right
now, get a brilliant.org forward slash.
Biographics you'll also find a
link in the description below.
Sir Isaac Newton is regarded as one of
the greatest scientists who ever lived.
His breakthrough idea about motion
influenced every area of physics,
allowing other great thinkers
to stand on his shoulders,
yet news and was also a man at
odds with his public perception,
a secret our chemist and a heretic
who risked his life to write about the
feelings of the Anglican
Church in today's biographics.
We're uncovering the truth
about the real Isaac Newton.
Hm Isaac Newton
was born on January the fourth
1643 and will's thought,
but by cost or worth the small town in
the country of Lincoln, Sharon England's,
he was a premature baby who was so small
that his mother said that he would have
fit inside a quarter
mark with room to spare.
The doctor who delivered him didn't
think that he'd survive his first week.
Newton's father who was also named Isaac,
had died three months
before the child was born.
He had been a successful farmer and
his wife Hannah was left a financially
comfortable widow for the next three
years. She raised young Isaac alone.
Then in 1646 she remarried to
becoming Mrs Barnabas Smith.
The relationship between young eyes,
I could just step father.
It was a difficult one and the boys
spends lots of time in the care of his
grandmother, Hannah and Barnabas went
on. So you have three children together.
Benjamin,
Mary and Hannah.
Isaac seems to have gotten on well
with his half siblings though his
relationship with his mother
was tempestuous when he
was 19 Isaac wrote a list
of sins for which he wanted to repent.
One of them was threatening to burn
down his family home with his mother and
stepfather and cite it Isaac and
did a village school sporadically,
but we didn't begin as formal schooling
until the age of 12 when he enrolled at
King's school.
Then grounds and England's initially he
showed little interest in his studies
and it's performed poorly in all
subjects. However, all of a sergeant,
he had something of an attitude change
and he decided to apply himself more
seriously.
When he was 17 Isaac stepfather died.
There's another looking to
a oldest sons potential.
As the family breadwinner attempted
to make a farmer out of him.
This Isaac had no intention
of becoming a farmer. In fact,
he detested the very thought of
spending his life out in the fields.
Unfortunately,
after a few months,
that master at King's school
interceded on Isaac's behalf,
convincing Anna it was
best suited back with them.
Isaac had been bullied by another students
chose to response by hour to doing
the bully and his cronies.
Academically,
Isaac achieved outstanding
academic results.
He was the top performing students of
1660 displaying and amazing aptitude for
all subjects.
In June of 1661 Isaac began studying at
Trinity College at Cambridge University
in order to pay for his studies.
He worked out one side of his study hours
serving meals and running errands for
his professors.
The 18 year olds it enter trinity with
the goal of becoming a minister of the
Church of England's.
However,
at some point within that first
year he changed direction.
It is unclear why he decided not
to pursue a life in the church,
but from his later writings it was clear
that he was forming beliefs about gone
the work rather at odds with the
doctrine of the Anglican church.
The foundation of the education
that Newton was receiving
at Trinity College was
based on the teachings of Aristotle.
He was fascinated with these ideas.
This objects,
it's many of the concepts sweat,
not based on evidence but merely on the
great philosophers assumptions and his
ideas. Using the became increasingly
focused on the natural sciences as well as
philosophy.
He studied the works of such original
thinkers as day car Kaplow and Galileo
because the establishment have
not accepted the scientific
findings of these men.
Isaac did a lot of his study outside
of the classroom using an exorbitant
scientific ideas from
wherever you could get them.
So long as he was able
to test and prove them,
he would take these ideas on board and
then debate them with his professors and
fellow students.
In 1662 Newton filled the
pages of a notebook with a
list of 45 things he wanted
to study. They came under the
general heading of physics,
but unlike everyone else
who had gone before him,
nuisance didn't just pose the questions.
He also set out to answer them.
He began to divide these experiments in
order to find the answers that he was
looking for.
The following year,
however,
Newton's the focus was pulled away from
his list of physics based questions.
He became fascinated with the
works of rainy day Carson.
This led him to an in
depth study of mathematics.
They call it applied to the
Arabic discipline of Algebra
two geometry and called
it Algebraic geometry.
Using graduated from Trinity College in
August of 1665 he did not receive the
stellar grades that his
talents mirrors said,
which was probably due to the fact
that he spent so much time on his own
personal studies. At this time, all
of Europe, it was being ravaged.
The bonding the bubonic plague in London,
one in every four people died.
Colleges were closed down in an attempt
to control the spread of the disease.
This bespoke ones,
Newton's continued formal education,
but he made great use of the
time for the next two years.
Isaac focused on his personal
studies from his family.
Home is the main areas of study where
calculus, lunar motion, and optics.
He know at the time to mull over all of
the knowledge that he had accumulated at
Cambridge.
It's relate this to the world around him.
This led them to more questions.
Three of the most fundamental of which
were why do things always fall down?
Why doesn't the moon fall to earth
and why the planets stay in orbit?
Newton was convinced the mathematics
would lead to the answers to these
questions.
He developed a new form of maths,
which he called flux is
the basis of modern day.
He knows you wrote about this
time in his life. At this time,
I was in the prime of my age of invention,
men's minded,
mathematics and philosophy.
More than anytime since using re-sentence
Duke Cambridge in the spring of 1667
he had developed into a role
the acuity of 23 year old man.
He was a loner with no friends.
He was content to spend hours
on ends just with his thoughts.
Many people dismissed him as just
being an absent minded recluse,
none of his contemporaries that any
idea that he was grappling with an
understanding of punditry motion.
He took up a position as a fellow
of the college and held a number of
prestigious positions
over the coming years.
In 1669 Isaac published his first work,
which was called analysis
by infinite series.
It was an investigation of cubic equations
and comes in three dimensions and was
well received and the wider scientific
community. As a fellow of Cambridge,
Newton was expected to become an
ordained priest in the Anglican church,
but his opposition to the belief in the
Trinity Doctrine held him back when he
was appointed as Lucchese and professor
of mathematics at the college officials
pressed for his ordained ship.
He managed to pull it off the requirements
and he received the promotion.
Now Age 27 years in hell is one of
the most prestigious positions in the
mathematical world.
As an occasion professor,
he was required to lecture on mathematics
and place copies of his moods in the
university library, a requirement's,
which he rarely complied with.
He began lecturing on the subject of
optics with his notes forming the basis of
his book optics.
His work on optics led Newton to
focus on improving the working of the
refracting telescope.
He was grappling with the problem of how
to get the different colors of light to
come into focus at the
same spot on the lens.
He failed to solve this issue and so
turned his attention to the reflecting
telescope. In 1668 Newton produced the
first working reflective telescope,
a building on the work of Scottish
mathematician, James Gregory.
He used his telescope to look into the
night sky where he was able to observe
the four means of the planet Jupiter.
Hmm.
In 1671 using was nominated as a member
of the British Royal Society to support
this proposed candidacy.
He wrote a letter on the nature of light,
which was red at the
society's next meeting.
It calls mixed reactions with some
praising his observation and others
vehemently opposed to it
using was admitted to the
Royal Society in 1672 mocking
his entry into the legitimate
scientific community.
Up until then he had done
his work in bice elation,
but now he was rubbing shoulders with the
most prominent scientists in the world.
Isaac immediately came to loggerheads
with most of the respected members of the
royal society. Robert Hook was the
curator of experiments for the society.
Unlike the quiet, reserved nusend
hook was loud and outgoing.
He objected to Newton's writings
on the nature of lights,
which challenged the conventional
wisdom over a period of four years,
Hook road 10 published
objections to Newton's ideas,
each of which were counted by Isaac.
Use it in the heat of
the constant quarreling,
which was a part and parcel of
being a member of the royal society.
And it's after 15 months he
quit the organization, the
secretary of the society,
Henry Oldenburg,
pleaded with him to stay assuring
him that he was greatly respected.
But Newton stayed away from the
society for the next two years.
Okay.
By 1675 newtons, refusal to take the
priesthood was becoming a serious problem.
There was becoming a talking points
which was proving embarrassing to the
college with it looking as if
he would lose his position.
He turned to his men Zuarin's, former
Lucasian professor Isaac Barrow for help.
Barry suggested that he rides a King
Charles the second and request a special
dispensation allowing him to continue
in his position without entering the
priesthood.
Using was generally dissatisfied with
the way that the Anglican church or
devolved is maintained or any of the
trappings of the Catholic Church,
which he objected to.
But his biggest problem was with
the doctrine of the trinity.
He could not accept that God and Jesus
will one in March of 1675 and years and
traveled to London to file for a special
dispensation. So it's really fun.
Surprise. It was granted
without question. In fact,
the king removed the priesthood
requirements for all future new occasion
professorships in November of 60 90 a
bright comments appeared over the skies in
England. It was tracks and commented
on by the leading scientists,
including Newton and a new role
society member named Edmund Halley.
In 1684 the two men got
together to discuss the shape
of the orbits of planets.
Haney was impressed with Newton's ideas
and persuaded him to present his works
in written form to the royal society.
Now,
just before we get into
the rest of Newton's life,
I do want to take a moment to thank the
people who make this video possible and
not be brilliant.
And I know these mid role ads,
they're not great for the story here,
but these videos are long,
so I hope you appreciate it. I need to
have sponsors to make them possible.
They're pretty expensive and time
consuming to prick juice. Now,
brilliance are a learning platform which
teaches three something called active
learning. I like biographies, which are
a nice way to learn about people's lives,
like a Newton. Learning about
science, it's a little bit trickier.
I don't know if you've ever had to sit
down with a science textbook. I have.
And you know this shore a lot
of moments where it's like, Huh,
I didn't really understand
what is going on.
And then you read it again and you still
don't get it. This is passive learning.
It's no a brilliance is about brilliance,
have active learning and they give
you something super short to read.
It's really easy and then you can
immediately apply that to a problem.
You just rinse and repeat that and
suddenly you're understanding all sorts of
stuff that you didn't think you would be.
I've used brilliance and I think you
should go try it out just to see how
fascinating it is that a complex
subject can be grasped quite so easily.
Obviously with this
biography about Newton,
they've got lots of stuff
related to what he was up to you.
So nice tie in that you could spoil
biographics by going to brilliant.org
forward slash buyer graphics.
And let's get back to Newton
for the next 18 months.
Newton was consumed with the
rising of his masterwork,
which he called Principia Mathematica.
He was so absorbed with it.
So there's the often neglected to eat
or sleep and there's three volume work.
He brought together the
results of 20 years of study,
observation and thinking about nature.
He began by laying out a
series of definitions that
underpinned his thoughts on
the natural world. These definitions
for such things as inertia matter,
mass and momentum. They still stand
today with his basis established.
He then laid out his three laws of motion,
the law of inertia and north acceleration
and the law of action and reaction
these ins and led to his
most groundbreaking idea,
the law of universal gravitation,
the law of gravitation.
It flew in the face of Aristotle's
2000 year old teaching that the earth
operates under one set of rules while
the sun, the moon, planets and stars,
and they follow different rules according
to news and there was one law that
governs the motion of everything in the
universe. The Principia was presented,
the Royal Society in 60 86 roboto can
immediately accused Newton of plagiarizing
his ideas. Despite this, the volume, it
was well received when it was published.
A year later,
it became an instant masterpiece.
The lower of universal gravitation
was accepted as the breakthrough that
explained everything from the motion of
the planets to the tones of the seat.
Despite the popular reaction
to Principia Newton's ideas,
they would not be taught in
universities for another 50 years
when he was a students at Cambridge.
And using that first come
into contact with Alchemy,
this Uda signs had its origins in
the works of Aristotle who taught.
So that all matter was composed
of four basic elements, earth,
fire and water. By adjusting the
proportions of any of these components,
it was believed that one thing could
be turned into another. Aristotle.
Also towards that each of the elements
was connected to a human emotion or a
characteristic. Newsland was
fascinated with these concepts,
even though they were completely at odds
with the rational evidence based way
that he synthesize to scientific
ideas from that time owned would see,
let us sort of double life where he
portrayed himself as the ultimate logical
thinker while pursuing Unorthodox
alchemist experiments, uh,
away from prying eyes.
At the same time,
he also developed a number of religious
views that were decidedly outside of the
mainstream.
Starting in 1669 Newton
built up an extensive library
of alchemy related books.
He was obsessed with finding universal
truth and so alchemy as a means of doing
so. He wrote thousands of
words of notes on the sub.
Jackson's conducted hundreds of
experiments has inflammation.
It was eventually condensed
into a book which equals Clavis.
New Zealand has a deep and
abiding interest in religion.
Over the course of his life. He wrote
more than a million words on the subjects,
but very few of them were actually
published during his lifetime.
Through his studies of the Hebrew language
and careful study of the scriptures,
he became convinced that
modern Christianity was not
following the model that
had been set out by Jesus.
You didn't fundamentally disagreed with
the doctrine of the holy trinity at the
time.
This was a act of heresy punishable by
imprisonment or even worse by writing
about it.
Even if his work was unpublished,
he was putting his very life at risk
to important works of scriptural
interpretation that were
published in the century.
After his death were observations on the
prophecies of Daniel and the apocalypse
of some John and the chronology
of Angel and kingdoms.
Amended Knudsen was fascinated
with Solomon's temple
believing that the building
was a paradigm for the universe and a
pattern for the future of the human race.
It was his belief that the architecture
of the temple health secrets do
uncovering the mysteries of the universe
and reveals a future Bible prophecy
from his. He gave predictions now
the ends of the Catholic Church.
The return of Christ wins
the Day of Judgment in 1687
using became involved in a
conflict between King James the
second and Cambridge University.
The Benedictine monk has
requested a receipt of a
master's degree without having
to swear an oath of allegiance
to the Anglican Church.
The monk appealed to the king,
issued a mandate stating that the
university must admit the man without
requiring the oath.
Newton came out on behalf
of the university and with
soon appointed to represent
them.
At the Commission hearing at Westminster
is arguments proved persuasive and the
monk was not admitted to the university
in January,
1699 using was elected to public
office when he became the university's
representative in the convention.
Parliaments with his new position
came a change in personality.
You transformed from an introverted
retiring academic to a friendlier,
more outgoing public servants.
In 1690 newtons suffers a
period of depression and
mental exhaustion apparently
compounded by a dose of influenza.
He recovered and Spence the 60
nineties focused on the moon's orbit.
His work required the obtain astronomical
readings from the first astronomer,
Royal John farmstead.
That's the two men they did not get on.
They quarreled from the very start with
the relationship eventually completely
breaking down.
This meant that Newton was unable to
complete his investigation into lunar
cycles. In 1696 newtons, salty, higher
paying job in the public service.
He was awarded the position
of warden of the royal mint.
This drop required to move to London,
which is where he actually
lived until his death.
He oversaw the recoiling of
old silver and gold coins.
He also standardize the
weights and composition of
coins so that he was able to
bring British coinage.
A much greater degree of accuracy.
Then was seven known before
three years into the job.
He was promoted to master
of the meds the draw,
which she held until his death
paid around 1500 pounds a year,
which was a huge amount for the times
in 1703 mucin now the most famous
scientist in the land to send it to
the presidency of the royal society.
He held this position until his death
in 1,705 he received a knighthood from
Queen Anne.
However,
his acclaim among the scientific community
was strange with an ongoing dispute
with gem and polymath Godfrey live in.
It's over which of them should get the
credit for the invention of calculus.
Although New Zealand was the first
to develop the basic concepts,
live minutes published his
work on Calculus before Newton.
The issue divided the leading
scientists of the time.
Yeah.
During the last few decades of his life
and you didn't spend a great deal of
time revising his most famous
work Principia Mathematica.
A second edition was published in 1713
with a third and final version appearing
in 70 26 he also indulged a passion for
Biblical studies spending days on end
compiling notes on the history
of the ancient Hebrews.
It is clear that Newton was keen to
insure his legacy lived on beyond this
physical years.
He sat for a number of portraits and
sculptures were cost of him still vote.
He professed an outward appearance of
humility, making the following statement.
I do not know what's I may appear
to the world, but to myself,
I seem to have been only
like a boy playing on the
seashore and diverting myself
in now and then finding a smoother paddle,
Laurie, prettier shell and ordinary.
Whilst the Great Ocean of truth
lay all undiscovered before me.
The last years of Newton's
life was spent with his niece,
Kathryn Barton conduit and her husband's
in his seventies he began to suffer
from breathing problems prompting and
moved from London to Kensington where the
I was fresher in 1725 at the age of 82
he was confined to his beds with severe
lung problems.
Coughing fits were constant since he
suffered from an uncontrolled bladder.
By early 1727 he seemed to
have recovered some wash.
He actually felt good enough to preside
over the Royal Society Meeting on
February the 28th but that efforts, it was
too much for him. Upon his return home,
he was again confined to bed and now
early March is doctors diagnosed kidney
stone and his condition steadily
worsens throughout that month.
Dee passed away in the
early hours of March,
the 31st 1727 using was awarded the great
honor of being buried at Westminster
Abbey.
His funeral service was the
most extravagant ever held
in England for a natural
philosopher. So already hope you
enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos
several times a week.
If you don't at something else
to watch right now, they why not?
Check out some videos from the archive
that are linked to you on the screen now
and as always,
thank you for watching.